anger and fear in the streets of lima
rivals fighting and throwing stones
it's one week before a run-off election
and either candidate keiko fujimori or
pedro castillo
could win peru's presidency opinion
polls say
it's too close to call on sunday a final
tv
debate to win over 20 percent of
undecided voters
mr castillo with your hate and divisive
language you've contributed
to those aggressions against journalists
you're used to throwing rocks
this is the stone thrown at our caravan
keiko fujimori is the daughter of former
president alberto fujimori
and trails pedro castillo by nearly 3
percentage points
she's facing a popular rival and has
been charged with organized crime money
laundering obstruction of justice and
perjury
that's for allegedly receiving 1.2
million dollars
from a brazilian construction company
during her first presidential bid
in 2011. she could face up to 30 years
in prison if convicted
doesn't it ring about it when we talk
about corruption isn't it a synonym of
fukhimari
doesn't it ring about that when we talk
about corruption one must have a speck
of morals
but that is unimportant for many of her
supporters who fear castillo will impose
a communist government
nationalize private companies or
confiscate their bank accounts
something castillo denies castillo has
radical ideas he wants to crush
all institutions and impose communism we
don't want what happened in venezuela to
happen here
analysts say the outcome of the debate
will define who wins the election
analysts say castillo's proposals are
vague and inconsistent
but his plan to reform the free market
model has kept him on the lead
pollsters say more than 80 percent of
peruvians want some
economic policy changes
[Applause]
while many fear castillo's plans others
are welcoming change
fujimori represents her father's
authoritarian style
where women were sterilized by force
labor stability was destroyed
a constitution that doesn't benefit the
people castillo will nationalize our
natural resources
that's where we'll get funds for health
and education
with tens of thousands of people dead
and about two million infected
the pandemic has taken a major toll in
peru
two and a half million people are
jobless the country
is polarized a divide that is likely to
continue
even after the election mariana sanchez
al jazeera lima peru